journée noire sur les routes
d'indre-et-loire rengaine bien connue
des vacanciers un peu moins des citadins
surtout en plein été c'est pourtant le
cauchemar que vivent les tourangeaux
depuis hier depuis la fermeture du rond
point saint sauveur pour travaux les
explications avec léa turquier et lucas
turcy
des fils qui n'en finissent pas depuis
hier aux heures de pointe ça bouchonne à
tour en cause deux axes d'entrée de la
ville fermé pour travaux une sortie de
la rocade ouest et le rond point saint
sauveur avec des répercussions jusqu'à
l'avenue de grammont ce mardi les
automobilistes tentent de s'adapter a
pris un peu d'avancé mais partira pas
avant pour pour gérer le truc donc
savoir pour partir au relâchement avant
parce que du coup on vend une muraille
buts en vingt cinq minutes mais bon en
partant plus tôt ça ira ça va nous
débrouillons connais des raccourcis on
n'attend pas si paisiblement au rond
point saint sauveur les travaux ne font
que commencer la circulation y est
fermée jusqu'au 26 août des itinéraires
de déviation sont proposés sauf qu'ils
sont eux mêmes très vite engorgé pas le
choix répond la municipalité qui incite
chacun à privilégier les mobilités
douces si les gens peuvent prendre le
vélo plutôt que la voiture qu'ils le
fassent effectivement on peut prendre le
rond point aujourd'hui à pied ou à vélo
ce sont des travaux qui ont qui ont un
impact est pour ça qu on les fait
pendant la période estivale pour essayer
de minimiser cet impact la situation
devrait toutefois s'améliorer rapidement
avec la réouverture de la sortie porte
de la riche sur la rocade ouest